A D-Class prisoner enters the chamber. It is
quiet, save for the subtle whipping sounds
coming from a bizarre shape in the middle of
the room. Upon closer inspection, it becomes
clear that the floating object isn’t one entity,
but a mass of smaller objects, all floating and
thrashing in the air. They’re ammunition, of
various calibers and sizes, spinning around
in a spherical form. The D-class becomes nervous,
but is ordered to proceed by Foundation personnel.
Slowly - inch by anxious inch - he advances
closer towards the mass of bullets...
His heart knocks harder against his chest with
every step he takes - the thumping begins to
deafen his ears. He could feel his throat
tightening up as the blood rushes to his head
and sweat starts to form on his brow. The sound
of the thrashing gets louder. With legs trembling,
and fingertips numbing, the D-class opens
his mouth in an attempt to let in a gasp of
air to calm his nerves. But before he could even
take a full breath, and in the blink of an eye,
countless bullets suddenly burst forth from
the mass, spraying the D-class relentlessly
with ammunition and killing him instantly. The
Foundation personnel watching this from safety
note down the events as they ponder the
question - why does this mass of living
ammunition act so volatile? Why are some able
to approach it safely while others are killed?
What is the secret of SCP-577?
Classified as Euclid, SCP-577 began as one of the
most mysterious objects in Foundation custody.
An animated mass of ammunition, those who were
able to get close enough to it observed that
the plurality of the bullets inside were
9mm, accompanied by a selection of 10mm
and .45 rounds. The bullets are normally
calm, moving in predictable patterns and
occasionally shifting the mass to reflect
other shapes, including cats and dogs.
But something else about the mass
concerns the Foundation much more.
The mass is growing. It is dramatically
larger than it was when it was first acquired
by the Foundation, and seems to be adding
approximately a thousand bullets per year.
This raises the question - can it
be contained permanently? Currently,
it is held in a standard large containment unit,
but it's quarters have been reinforced with the
Foundation’s best steel blast shielding. Due
to the danger to anyone who opens the door, the
entire facility is handled with remote technology
and can only be opened by approved personnel.
But someone needs to check
that everything is stable.
The Foundation learned the hard way that
entering the containment unit was a bad idea.
Any Foundation staff, ranging from a high-level
scientist to a standard security officer,
is met with immediate hostility from SCP-577’s
mass of bullets the second they approach
the entity. The bullets shoot out from the
mass with the speed of a standard handgun,
aiming directly at their target. This
indicates that SCP-577 is intelligent,
it is capable of seeing and reacting - and
it hates Foundation personnel with a passion.
Fortunately, the Foundation doesn’t
have to sacrifice it’s permanent staff.
SCP-577 is not the first entity to react with
hostility toward its captors - after all,
few of the specimens are happy to be
permanently contained in secure facilities.
So it was determined that D-class personnel
would be sent into the facility twice a year
to inspect it for any damage, make sure
the entity was still secure - and test
SCP-577’s reaction to the presence of different
people not from the Foundation’s staff.
And that’s where things got interesting.
Many of the D-class personnel didn’t trigger the
entity at all, resulting in neutral behavior.
However, those D-class who were initially
Foundation staff and demoted due to broken
policy were met with the same hostility as
current staff - indicating that SCP-577 was
not going to be fooled easily. The same happened
with some D-class with a specific background,
who were immediately sprayed with a violent
hail of bullets, causing injury or death.
Upon investigation,
every single one of those D-Class was revealed
to previously be a member of law enforcement.
However, some D-class personnel were
met with a very different reaction.
These people were the most likely to see
the other side of SCP-577, when it reduced
its hostile stance and instead took on a
friendly form. Appearing as a dog or cat,
it would even approach the D-class
in a welcoming manner. This was most
likely to happen when the D-class was formerly
homeless or had spent time in the prison system.
But one incident brought SCP-577’s
true nature into a new light.
D-28126 was the latest unfortunate conscript to be
sent into SCP-577’s chamber for an annual cleaning
and inspection. His duties were simple,
including to inspect the walls for damage,
clean out any stray material left
around by the bullets firing - as
well as any corpses that were left behind
- and make any needed repairs to the walls.
He would be wearing protective gear, but that
wasn’t always enough to protect someone from
the hail of bullets - and no one knew exactly
how the volatile mass of bullets would react.
But from the second the D-class entered, it was
clear this would be a very different encounter.
As soon as D-28126 entered, SCP-577 seemed to
take on a friendly posture. It shape-shifted
into the form of a large cat, and would frequently
approach the D-class while he was cleaning. The
D-class was confused at first, but soon seemed to
appreciate the company. He would occasionally stop
cleaning to pet the cat made out of bullets, but
as the work went on, he seemed to slow down. He
appeared to be crying, and eventually he stopped
working entirely and slumped against the wall.
The Foundation attempted communication
with him, but the D-class didn’t respond.
Soon, SCP-577 joined him against the wall,
and the D-class held him. His hand
was guided into the mass of bullets,
and it soon emerged holding a single bullet.
The D-class held the strange entity for a few
more minutes, before the staff’s insistence that
he exit the chamber grew stronger. He eventually
left, and the Foundation took him back into
custody and examined the bullet he was holding.
It was NOT a normal bullet.
The bullet was moving, almost as if it was
a beating heart as it throbbed up and down.
Upon closer inspection, it was revealed to be
covered with blood - but D-28126 had not been
hit by the bullet. He was completely uninjured,
but when he emerged from the chamber his hand
was covered in blood - exactly where he
had inserted it into the mass of bullets.
The bullet was sent to SCP facilities for
testing. The blood was not a match for D-28126.
But it was genetically similar - like a relative.
The D-class was brought back to the interrogation
chamber, and the bullet was returned to him.
He was apparently linked to SCP-577 somehow, and
identified himself by his name - Arturo Rojas.
His interviewer, Dr. Vanderbilt, asked him to
explain what happened, and Arturo explained
that the mass of bullets didn’t just turn into
a cat - it turned into a cat he knew as a child,
which had a uniquely shaped tail
that he would recognize anywhere.
The cat that was once helped
by Arturo...and his brother.
Arturo was questioned why he quit working
and began crying, and revealed that he heard
the mass of bullets say something, barely
audible. SCP-577 had whispered “I’m sorry”.
But what would a cat have to be sorry for?
Arturo became angry when Dr.
Vanderbilt questioned this,
but Dr. Vanderbilt continued and conceded
that Arturo recognized the cat somehow.
He prodded Arturo to share the rest of the
story - and Arturo eventually revealed the
root of his bond to SCP-577. Arturo and his deaf
brother Ricardo were homeless at a young age,
after their mother threw them out. While they
were living on the streets, they met a cat that
they gave a little of their food to from time
to time. The little cat became their constant
companion. They named him Duck, after Arturo’s
brother’s favorite sign language gesture.
But tragedy was just around the corner.
Duck and Ricardo were inseparable, with the little
cat essentially becoming a therapy pet to the boy.
But one day, Ricardo encountered a police
officer. The deaf boy couldn’t understand
the officer’s orders, and the officer didn’t
know or didn’t bother to use sign language.
Ultimately bullets were fired. Ricardo was
killed, another unarmed young man killed
in a police shooting, and Duck was left
alone. But the cat had one more job to do.
He had to lead Arturo back to his brother.
The area was swarming with police, and Arturo
never got a chance to say goodbye. He lashed
out at the only one he could - Duck. The
cat tried to comfort his surviving person,
but Arturo threw rocks at the cat and
chased him away. He never saw the cat again,
and was left alone with his grief. He saw
on the news days later that the officer
was cleared in the shooting, his brother
was blamed for threatening the officer,
and the news implied that Ricardo was a gang
member. Arturo was left without closure.
Until SCP-577 entered the picture.
Dr. Vanderbilt expressed his sympathies,
but wasn’t sure what any of this had to do
with the entity. Arturo explained further why he
started crying when he felt the pulsating bullet.
He had spent years sleeping next to Ricardo
- and he recognized his brother’s heartbeat.
The bullet was his brother’s heart, or at least
contained his essence. And for the first time
in ten years, Arturo was able to make peace not
just with the cat he had rejected out of grief,
but with the brother he had lost far too young.
The Foundation had answers - but
they only led to more questions.
Arturo had pulled a single bullet out of the
mass of SCP-577 - and it was the one containing
his brother’s heart. Was this the bullet that
killed Ricardo? Was every bullet in the mass
one that killed a person? Was the mass growing
with every new death? And if that was the case,
did the mass contain the combined memory -
and pain - of every life a bullet took? If so,
that would explain the compassion the entity
seems to hold for those who have been homeless or
imprisoned - as well as its intense hostility
for any sort of law enforcement figure.
For now, SCP-577 remains stable
and contained within its unit,
needing only standard upkeep of its cell to
avoid any breaches. But as it continues to grow,
Foundation authorities worry that it may get
strong enough to eventually breach containment.
But this is a tricky case for the Foundation.
The entity’s growth is out of their control,
and nothing they’ve done to date has stopped or
slowed it in any way. It seems something on the
outside is making it grow, and it shows
no sign of slowing down any time soon.
For another SCP with a benevolent side,
check out “SCP-2295 - The Bear with a Heart
of Patchwork”, or watch this video instead.